john what's happening brother how are we
doing so i
do a lot of traveling for work and my
wife and i
need some help uh strategizing and
getting the tools to be better when
we're apart
um my job has been traveling all over
the state out of state
for surprise trips of a day at a time up
to a week of a time i've got conferences
all across the country and
classes that i have to take all over the
place and
whenever we spend time apart it's
it's difficult i mean she's great and i
think she thinks that i'm pretty great
too
and we talk a lot but um sometimes it's
hard for me to focus on my job
sometimes it's you know just lonely
being in a hotel room
looking at the ceiling um are there ways
that we can or are there things that we
can do
to make the most and really you know
try and get through these times i i hate
feeling like i'm just you know
having to trudge through is there a way
that we can
make this time better when we're apart
man that's an awesome question i
appreciate that
um let's think through that together
first what kind of work do you do
i'm in cyber security cyber security and
so
even with the shutdown this year they've
had you traveling all over and still
attending things and learning things and
being in people's
drawers and whatnot less than usual
i work a lot with the cameras and door
won't
close or door won't open part of it so
uh
you know if the door won't close i gotta
go out there and close the door
gotcha okay and tell me about this
lovely wife of yours does she
vocalize that she doesn't like your job
do you just sense it on her
um no
she doesn't like my job and it's much
more of a
of a distance thing um
what is it about this job that makes you
want to keep this gig
i i i love it okay like from the bot
like it's what i'm supposed to be doing
okay ever since i was a little kid i
would you know be eating waffles in the
morning and
getting on the computer and learning
like this is it's a dream job
really what's the dream part about it
the cyber security part of it the
internet's part of it solving problems
part of it what's the dream job part of
it
it's it's the solving problems and you
know sometimes
it's it's more difficult for me to say
that in others when you're just a little
bit
you know deep into the problems but man
i just love it it's
it's a calling i i'd like to help
people and i like to you know
get online and you know fix problems and
work through stuff and be able to
provide solutions to people
you know immediately and seeing that
immediate result it just
it feels really really good and um i'd
like to think that i'm okay at it i get
paid to do it
yeah so i'm gonna tell you something
hard
that i just heard okay
when you were first called and you were
talking about your marriage
and your wife and she's you love her and
she's
good you said all the right things
you said all the right things that were
good and noble
and then when you talked about your job
you came alive
is that indicative of your relationship
i don't think so okay i'll be honest
with you
it's it's easy for me to get chatty
about my job
okay um i'm pretty close to the chest
about my relationship
it's it's actually pretty difficult for
me to talk to people about it
and you know that's that's part of the
reason why it's it's been tough for
for the both of us because i you know
i'm going on these trips and i feel like
i'm doing the same thing
you know and it's hard for me to reach
out to somebody and ask them you know
i've got this issue yeah and how am i
supposed to address it i'm used to just
fixing things
as i go and knowing the solution just
making it happen right
so at the end of the day you talk about
your job as your calling
something you've wanted since you were a
little kid and i want you to put
that same sort of
existential weight on your marriage and
specifically that woman that you
promised yourself to for the rest of
your life
and so i want you to have very clear in
your heart and mind that if
it ever comes to a point that you've got
to choose between the two that's going
to be
a difficult but clear-cut decision
and that will fall to your wife and i
want you to start there
because anything else is going to be
strategy and marriage can't survive on
strategy
strategy is a part of it right so you're
calling and saying what can i do
in a hotel well man they've got facetime
there's got all kinds of
of mutual games they've got all kinds of
stuff you can do
but at the end of the day your wife has
to feel
as valuable as this job is and she
probably
maybe she does she has to feel as though
not only have you is is your job a
calling something you've thought about
since you were a kid
but that she is your purpose
she is why you get up and will
get up in the middle of the night and
catching a 4am flight to go
fix a door right
yeah she is
and i can't i can't shake the fact john
that it
sounds like there's a a values
misalignment here okay
she has permission to struggle with you
being gone the same as you have
permission to struggle being gone
what it sounds like you all need to do
is get in a room together maybe i've
already done this
but get in a room together and
talk openly about what this job with the
travel is costing you
and maybe nothing maybe it's just
some frustration it's annoying right
it's just
man i'm gone a lot and i'm struggling
with it
or maybe it's way deeper than you think
maybe if you sit down with her
and y'all start going through she's
going to open up to you in a way that's
going to be really hard
or maybe this shutdown you've traveled
less and you've realized
this is my calling i love this job i
love problem solving i love doing on the
interwebs
but man i love being around my wife i
haven't been around her this much ever
and i love it and the thought of getting
back on the road is starting to
make me real uncomfortable and what i'll
tell you john is millions of people are
reconsidering
their profession and their quote unquote
calling i work with some of the best it
folks on planet earth and they go home
every day at five o'clock
and they make great money and they work
their butts off and we have
are recruiting them all of the time and
so i'm telling you to tell you there are
security jobs there are i.t jobs there
are internet
jobs that don't always require hopping
on a plane and heading off
and solving that sort of problem there
may be that you are going to find a job
that's different than the one you have
but in a similar field that still feels
like the calling is still meeting that
need with you
in terms of things you can do man it's
all about intentionality
it's knowing what is your wife missing
when you're gone besides your physical
presence
it could be a you're always writing
letters to one another that you can
hold and tangibly touch that you have
some rules and regulations and i say
rules loosely
um you've you're invited to one another
that you're always going to step out of
whatever meeting you are at these
intervals throughout a day
and talk to each other on facetime
you're going to make sure you facetime
each other watch a movie together at
night
all of this is a distant second and
third and fourth
actually being in the same room together
but it's again it's just strategies
um i actually like the idea of watching
a movie together with the other person
on facetime even though it's kind of
weird
but who who knows man but it starts with
you guys sitting down and figuring it
out
again i don't want to keep circling back
and saying the same thing over and over
john but there's something else here
that we could talk about for hours and
hours that sounds like there's a
disconnect between you and your wife
and this spiritual calling you have with
your work
so tonight i want you to turn all the
electronics off in the house
i want you to sit down with your wife
and i want you to have a hard
conversation with her
maybe not a harbin but a direct one an
open one on everything on the table
conversation
about how much you love her about how
much you love spending time with her
and i want you to ask her to be
vulnerable with you about
how she feels about your traveling how
she feels about you being gone how she
feels about you being home more this
season
and then come up with a plan together
co-create a plan together of what
travel's going to look like
what distance is going to look like and
is this
actually the right job for you long term
because man you may have been called to
this job
but you promised that young woman you
for the rest of your life